de retour à saint quentin en yvelines
pour découvrir une facette plus méconnus
de cette ville c'est à dire la nature
puisque on va découvrir une magnifique
réserve naturelle on ira voir un
apiculteur aussi
[Musique]
je m'appelle charlotte et je trouve
qu'on vit dans un pays formidable
les terroirs la gastronomie des paysages
mais ce que j'aime le plus sans doute
scellé rencontre si comme moi vous êtes
convaincus que les plus belles
découvertes se font souvent au bout de
la rue alors nous sommes faits pour nous
entendre
[Musique]
cette semaine on s'éloigne de la ville
direction l'étang de saint quentin en
yvelines passe de loisirs réserve
naturelle
ici la nature et aux portes de la ville
on improvise une petite promenade
matinale avec marie-hélène pour nous
parler de l'île de loisirs marie-hélène
on est en pleine nature et wheeler des
50 c'est assez incroyable dans un lieu
qui est à la fois nouveau puisqu'on est
dans une ville nouvelle mais qui en fait
a une histoire importante
et oui effectivement
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines d'effectivement que c'est un
une île de loisirs qui a été créée dans
les années 70 mais
son histoire effectivement date avant
tout de louis xiv
c'est ça exactement et les temps qui est
un étang artificiel a été réalisée dans
le cadre de grands travaux hydrauliques
pour amener l'eau dans l'est
fontaine de versailles et on va
clairement c'est que c'est quand même
extrêmement important d'impressionner
avec tous les jeux d'eau à versailles en
tout cas pour le souvent on a une
dizaine d' étant relié par le biais de
d'aqueduc de rigoles et
qui permettent d'alimenter effectivement
les eaux qui permettait d'alimenter les
eaux les eaux les eaux de versailles
et aujourd'hui c'est devenu un lieu plus
populaire ou vraiment les gens peuvent
venir pour pique et puis aussi
pour faire plein de choses vous allez
nous dire tout ce qu'on peut faire ici
le profusion d'activité exactement une
profusion d'activité puisque vous pouvez
venir faire du golf comme de
l'équitation centre de voile mais
également des activités plutôt nature
avec la ferme pédagogique
vous pouvez venir vous promener et puis
je vous dis yen à l'accrobranche donc
c'est aussi l'occasion de découvrir une
partie de ce site dans les arbres là
aussi c'est vrai que
je pense qu utilisent
tous les éléments de la nature pour pour
proposer des activités à 60 ans pour les
enfants mais c'est sympa aussi pour les
adultes
ah bah oui oui c'est sûr que c'est
l'occasion pour les adultes de se
retrouver notamment lors de week-ends
retrouver en famille ou entre amis pour
organiser des événements
divers autour d'un pique nique
mme à l'autre bout de l'étang j'ai
rendez vous avec johan et cyril pour une
balade dans la réserve naturelle
je découvre une oasis de paix pour de
nombreux oiseaux migrateurs les jumelles
sont de rigueur je vous invite à
regarder dans la langue vue on voit avec
précision les oiseaux qui sont sur le
site en ce moment vous avez le vanneau
huppé et la mouette rieuse la mouette
rieuse de gaston lagaffe c'est simple on
est au mois d'octobre bonne saison pour
regarder les oiseaux oui c'est une bonne
saison
alors même septembre c'est encore idéal
pour venir sur le site parce qu'en fait
c'est la période de migration de retour
c'est à dire que les oiseaux reviennent
du nord de l'europe et descendre vers le
sud en afrique et en fait la majorité
des oiseaux passent par le littoral mais
vous avez on est sur un axe secondaire
de migration d'accord si bien qu' il se
stationnent ici comme vous pouvez voir
donc ici en escale en fait et pourquoi
ils viennent ici précisément alors ils
viennent ici parce que
notamment le niveau de l'eau est bas en
cette saison ce qui fait que les
vasières apparaissent et pour un oiseau
c'est très intéressant parce que dans
les vasières vous avez tout un tas de
petites de nourriture des petits animaux
donc comme des insectes les mollusques
et l'armée et viennent se nourrir et
comme le site est très tranquille
ils peuvent rester en stationnement sans
risquer de se faire déranger
donc si c'est un peu là la cantine des
c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça c'est une
bonne cantine un bon endroit y
connaissent l'adresse y reviennent ils
savent qu'on mange bien là nous présente
jaune
johan vous êtes conservatrice ou ici
dans cette réserve de saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est pas très courant d'avoir une
réserve naturelle en pleine ville
mais en fait on y trouve plein de choses
ici en fait ça oui à beaucoup de oui-oui
d'espèces d'oiseaux où il ya beaucoup
d'espèces d'oiseaux on a depuis trente
ans que la réserve naturelle existe on
en a identifié 2 163 ont ce n'est pas ce
qui n'est pas rien surtout pour un site
qui est en zone périurbaine
donc la nature arrive en fait la nature
sauvage girard exceptionnel arrive à
vivre à côté de nous mêmes à côté de nos
villes donc on n'est quand même pas si
loin que ça de la tour eiffel et ça
fonctionne alors ça fonctionne parce
qu'on voit là on répartit bien le
territoire sur l'île de loisirs et la
réserve naturelle c'est vraiment une
zone de refuge pour ces oiseaux
et voilà donc les activités de loisirs
peuvent se pratiquer sur les loisirs
souvent dans la journée et puis ensuite
à la fin de la journée les oiseaux
reprennent l'ensemble plaindre parce que
c'est quand même très préservé ici on
vend pas ici come on come on veut win a
vu donc c'est quand même un dieu qui est
fermé les bateaux de loisirs peuvent pas
venir jusqu'ici
c'est c'est très très près de vous êtes
pour préserver cet équilibre il faut des
règles de vie en fait qu'ils sont assez
simple c'est les oiseaux sauvages sont
véritablement farouche et donc faut
limiter le dérangement à limiter le
dérangement c'est limiter l'intrusion
humaines du public donc la réserve
naturelle a été
clôturée et maintenant vous pouvez la
visiter mais toujours accompagnés d'un
guide nature donc on peut accueillir
jusqu'à 7000 personnes sur la réserve
naturelle dans l'année quand on peut
avoir un million de visiteurs sur l'île
de loisirs et c'est à ce prix que l'
équilibre fonctionne alors cet équilibre
il est il varie aussi en fonction des
saisons on voit pas forcément tous les
mêmes oiseaux c'est ça on voit pas
forcément les mêmes choses non plus dans
la vie les oiseaux oui c'est là la
diversité a les ailes et sur toute
l'année c'est à dire que à l'hiver bat
vous avez les oiseaux qui passent leur
hiver ici pour eux c'est ainsi nous
avons des grand nombre d'oiseaux à voir
en mouvement donc ça c'est intéressant
la partie qui intéresse les scolaires
notamment c'est au printemps parce que
là vous avez la reproduction vous avez
les ni les adultes les jeunes laurie
nourrissage donc c'est aussi assez
attachant en fait pour non publique
les t bonds c'est une peur d'un peu de
transition et puis dès que la fin de
l'été arrive ya tous les oiseaux qui ont
fait leur production en or qui
redescendent est donc là on attend on
attend les oiseaux rares avec impatience
j'ai dû ajouté scor annonce pour moi
observer des oiseaux
sur la pièce d'eau a vu des canards
qu'on dit plongeurs enfin donc ce sont
des véhicules comment bon et véhicule
comme on peut voir un flic morillon
qu'on a beaucoup en hivernage sur les
gangs et puis sinon elle qu'à naples
connu le golfeur de tout le monde
connaît un peu difficile voilà lui
s'armant d'un petit peu et là c'est un
gars qui va en fait mettre la partie
avant de son corps sous l'eau et puis on
voit les fesses en l'air quand on fait
souvent vois ça tu es tu montreras en
fait tout ça aux enfants vous adultes
aussi voilà aux enfants aux adultes ont
commencé au niveau de la maternelle en
général moyenne section plutôt vers la
fin de l'année grande section et puis on
va jusqu'aux étudiants
je collèges lycées et facultés mi6 et
puis aussi des adultes qui viennent là
par exemple un différend entre septembre
au graff les observateurs il ya des
personnes qui sont très attachés au site
qui viennent depuis 25 ans ici donc ça
c'est formidable et on leur montre en
fait c'est un patrimoine naturel ici et
c'est important de montrer parce qu'il
ya cac avec cette compréhension et puis
cette appropriation du public qu'on peut
continuer à protéger
voilà éduquer d'un côté et puis
sensibiliser à l'ours plus le grand
public
et puis l'éducation qui est vraiment
avec les scolaires et les centres de
loisirs
fou
je sans toi
en effet avec le public est-ce qu'on
s'imagine pas qui va être inauguré la
suite heureux se lire comme le niveau
est très bas en fait il vous profite
pour aller chasser un peu plus il avait
décollé c'est vrai qu'il ya pas trop
déranger quand vous voyez tout à l'heure
avec votre collègue est en train de
débattre sur un poison ou est-ce qu'il a
le bras cassé mon équivalent bac passé
en fait c'est
facile de savoir 7-1 face et surtout la
rencontre débattaient sur les espèces
qu'on appelle les limicoles les fameuses
oiseaux qui se nourrissent dans la vase
est en fait une grande diversité de
l'école et donc pour arriver à les
différencier quand on en a quand on en
voit pour la première fois on croit
qu'ils sont tous pareils en fait en
quart temps de près on voit qu'il ya des
mecs qui sont longs plus long que la
longueur de la tête du plus court
légèrement courbé ou recourbé
la couleur des pâtes change aussi quoi
ça peut être autre serbe a peut être
joué mais ça change en fonction des
saisons aussi alors voilà ça change en
fonction des espèces et en fonction de
l'âge de l'oiseau c'est pour ça que vous
voilà déjà mais sans le guide
oui oui moi j'espère le guide des années
de pratique
oui oui c'est bien ça permet de vérifier
d'être sûr de soi rebond après avec la
pratique dans les liquides sai on peut
s'en défaire
mais moi j'aime quand on quitte les
oiseaux pour le golf national je dois
avouer que je ne suis pas une grande
professionnelle de ce sport mais ce
n'est pas grave
le pro c'est paul et il va tout nous
expliquer on démarre notre balade au
début du 18e trou 144 hectares c'est ça
ne sert de verdure de de green
oui le parcours des records on est sur
144 hectares il ya trois parcours il ya
2 18 trous et à neuf trous sur ce site
plus de zones d'entraînement wee cc 144
heures 444 hectares de nature alors le
golf de guyancourt c'est ce qu'on fait
c'est le plus grand de france c'est ça
alors c'est le golf national
alors je dirais c'est difficile à dire
si c'est le plus grand parce qu'il ya
d'autres complexes ou équipements qui en
quarante cinq trous mais en est le golf
national
dans son activité de tous les jours avec
des tournois tout le temps plus la ryder
cup
on peut dire que c'est la vitrine du
golf français c'est un endroit aussi
donc vous sort organisé des compétitions
extrêmement importante voilà vous avez
parlé de la ryder cup
qu'est ce que c'est exactement la ryder
cup alors c'est un tournoi qui existe
depuis 1927
c'est un match tous les deux ans entre
les meilleurs aux américains une équipe
des meilleurs américains deux joueurs et
des européens c'est une véritable guerre
qui s'est installée de films 1927 parce
que je joue pour la gloire il n'y a pas
de j'espère que vous creuse pas
décrocher quand même non non non nous
non plus non non mais y aura pas mal de
changements sur le site parce que 60 60
70 mille personnes par jour sur le site
pendant une semaine ça va ça va nous
emporter
on est dans un endroit où la tension est
à son comble le 18e trou
ça c'est ça et effectivement ces
derniers trous du parcours
vraisemblablement on va vivre des
moments l'année prochaine du 28 au 30
septembre
magique devant peut-être un milliard de
téléspectateurs
finalement ce sont 1000 personnes autour
c'est la deuxième compétition la plus
visionnée 3e 3e derrière les jeux
olympiques et la coupe du monde du foot
en termes d'audience mondiale c'est
troisième événement méconnu en france
mais de plus en plus connue parce que
c'est en france
qu'est ce qu'on doit affronter sur ce
18e trou alors là beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de haut parce que c'est un
cadeau
voilà en fait on est à peu près on à 420
mètres pour aller jusqu'au drapeau là
bas les pros vont toucher les greens
c'est à dire aller aux drapeaux en deux
coups uniquement seulement deux coups
les amateurs cédant 3
il faut quand même expliqué qu' ici
avant c'était du blé absolument 1980 6 5
6 l'idée est venue de monsieur qui
s'appelle hubert chez nous qui était le
directeur général de la fédération
française de vol et architecte de golf
de dire voilà il nous faut un site
il nous faut un golf national et après
de avoir un site qui pouvait aider la
france entraîné des jeunes pour trouver
un champion il nous manquait jean n'a
pas besoin visiblement c'est vraiment
pour l'équipe donc tout ça ça a été
construit par la main de l'homme
exactement c'est tout est ici artificiel
c'était deschamps tout plat de blé à
perte de vue
même les petites collines là exactement
300 camions par jour pendant
[Musique]
j'ai été très étonné que tout le monde
n'est pas un pantalon à carreaux et une
casquette sur la tête on a croisé des
golfeurs médecin c'est fini le golf
devient von finck qui jeunes mais en
tout cas on n'est pas obligé d'être
habillé comme un lord anglais terminée
bon bah c'est bien du coup aucun sens
plus des a priori sur sur le golfe
qu'elle a priori on pourrait casser
aussi parce que le prix d'argent
bonjour dans le fichier avec le matériel
compris au moins de 50 euros par mois
vous vous êtes anglais et justement nous
plaire on est sur le dernier trou on
voit le drapeau qui est là alors avant
qu'on se quitte puisqu'on arrive à la à
la fin du parcours j'ai une petite
question à vous poser finalement
qu'est-ce qui a inventé le golf c'est
c'est les anglais où ces landais alors
déjà scène les écossais en écosse et des
britanniques
je pense que peut-être des irlandais
peuvent dire qu'ils ont
taper dans une balle avec un club avec
une canne avant les écossais mais des
écossais c'est eux qui ont quand même
fermé le jeu de golf avec les règles et
peut-être le premier parcours véritable
parcours
à l'origine le joueur qu'on vient de
voir il est fort où il est fort on
dirait qu'il est il a beaucoup la durée
les parcs ou les trois services
3h10 sur le questionner sur le parcours
des prophètes l'albatros est simplement
trois services c'est pas vrai les
citations super vous allez en groupe
vous êtes super intendant du gol à saint
louis
qu'est ce que ça veut dire en gros
moyens et des bons amis
mais mon métier c'est un espace vert
spécialistes un espace vert notamment
n'ont pas nous c'est sportif qu'est ce
qu'il y avait commencé fait justement de
golf vous voyez vous il ya plusieurs
plusieurs épaisseurs
on voit que le gazon est très très très
très dense on n'a jamais ça chez soi
comme en fait ça s'est compliqué ça vous
donne une idée ici on est sur une grille
ou green day assure l'excavation des 50
cm à 5 cm et écossais de la terre on a
mis une couche de 20 cm de gravier donc
pour les fêtes traînant que ce soit vous
sentez la fermeté ces fermes canon
marseille parce que nous nous mettons il
ya plus de 30 centimètres de sable les
30 cm du sol que ce qu'est ce qu'on
appelle les la sonde racines et aubade
développer tous les racines pour avoir
une pleine santé avec une terre doute on
doit militer en même temps c'est
extrêmement dense
il n'y a pas quelque chose qui vous
manque un peu non rien parce que les
balades ça creuse quand même et on
encore rien goûter ici je suis monté au
vol dans la deux chevaux de jacky il est
apiculteur dans la ville de plaisir
on m'a dit qu'il faisait l'un des
meilleurs miel du coup
[Musique]
merci jacques lui pour cette petite
balade nostalgique pratique de chaud
quand même ça reste une valeur sûre
absolument on est ici presque chez toi
hein
en tout cas dans ta deuxième maison
c'est ma maison de campagne
oui alors on est où exactement alors là
nous sommes en plein pour ainsi dire en
plein centre-ville de plaisir nous
sommes en bordure de la forêt de sainte
apolline qui représente à peu près 300
hectares qui appartient au conseil
général
et toi ta passion c'est la baignoire
mais j'essaye de conserver donc ce
patrimoine génétique que nous avons qui
est connu depuis la nuit des temps
depuis 15 minutes et c'est une abeille
qui est spécifique à ce territoire
fallait elle existe ailleurs mais allez
c'est une abeille en délicats notre
mutware français notamment
donc c'est une abeille vraiment typique
qui connaît très très bien sa région
qu'il connaît bien et connaît bien
lecteurs c'est exactement ce dont tu as
là ce qu'elle a à faire
ça fait combien d'années que ça fait à
peu près oui ça fait 30 ans que je fais
de l'apiculture c'est quoi un bon
endroit pour poser une ruche il ya des
conditions spécifiques à respecter lors
qu'il y aura effectivement des
conditions à respecter
il faut bien sûr qu'ils aient de la
végétation ici on souffre et a faim
c'est parfait il faut que la végétation
de l'année qui est des fleurs donc
comment la belle saison qu'elles soient
suffisamment abondante qu'il y ait de la
diversité
est-ce qu'on peut aller leur dire
bonjour ces vraiment bien sûr moi de
leur dire bonjour
alors pour leur dire bonjour par contre
on va aller faire un petit peu de fumée
on a préparé dans six mois a les mains
tu nous manques comment fait on va leur
faire de la fumée pour leur dire bonjour
et pour perturber les phéromones qui
vont être distribués par les airs par
les abeilles il nous permettra
d'intervenir à l'intérieur de la ruche
sans éventuellement se faire compliqué
d'accord il sans se faire trop piquée
ouhlala il reste donc encore mais partie
ça dépend ensuite de la météo
ah et puis savoir les manipulations que
l'on nous montre comment on va réaliser
pour des faits bien sûr les douceurs
pour l'enfumage on procède comment et
bien je vais préparer donc de la fumée
sera de la fumée froide
on n'est pas là pour les brûlés non plus
donc on va faire de la fumée froide
donc on prépare une petite un petit
morceau de carton puis on prépare donc
c'est en plus cette femme on évite en
général que ça c'était donc il ya un
souffle et ses cinq frères qui va
distribuer de l'air par en bas
ensuite on referme
d'accord on est pareil on est pas mais
on y va allez on y va
il paraît qu'une ruche c'est tout un
monde
oui comment on fait pour le découvrir ce
monde maintenant qu'on a notre petite en
fumoir et bien maintenant nous avons un
enfumoir qui fait de la fumée froide
mais on va leur dire bonjour et donc
pour leur dire bonjour je vais faire
donc il peut de fumer à l'entrée de la
ruche avec délicatesse aussi donc ça va
leur donner un signal
comme quoi on va 20 certainement
intervenir et la réaction chez les
abeilles c'est que lorsqu'il ya du feu
un petit peu comme chez nous s'il y
avait le faire la maison on prend les
choses de plus les plus importantes qui
ont plus de valeur chez elle c'est le
miel et donc elles vont se gorger de
miel elles vont se mettre une miette de
jabot d'accord et puis elles seront
prêtes éventuellement à partir si le
besoin s'en faisait sentir
et jusqu'où alors elles vont donc sur un
rayon de 3 km 3 km ça représente à peu
près 27 kilomètres de surface qui est
butinée par sept kilomètres carrés mais
bon un petit peu comme nous si elle
trouve à portée de main
on pas trop elle est fatiguée plus
moment principal c'est qu'ils aient des
sources de données qu tard à proximité
donc allez on va les ouvrir là ok je
retire le toit que je mets sur le côté
ensuite je retire ce l'antenne de
couvrot cadre c'est une protection et on
va commencer à arriver ça s'éteint une
toile pour récupérer la propolis de
façon exceptionnelle puisqu'on a maroc
on a nos roues pas de particules de
peinture ou de particules de bois ou de
ou des déchets parasites
ici on est en octobre prévu octobre
qu'est ce qui se passe en ce moment dans
la rue système est bien en octobre on
peut considérer que c'est la fin de la
saison
c'est la fin de la saison d'apiculture
c'était on à récolter le miel les
abeilles se mettent donc commencent à
prendre leurs quartiers d'hiver
la reine va prendre beaucoup moins
puisqu'on plein 16 ans la reine pour à
peu près 2009 par jour est bien là les
la reine va diminuer et même m a fait ça
compte à 0 en attendant les premières
fleurs du mois de février qui sont les
chatons de noisetier notamment zaki
après avoir risqué tous les dangers en
mouvement une ruche est-ce qu'on peut
passer un truc sympa a bien sûr bon
plein de choses qui sont bonnes dans le
dans la ruche il était à notre miel du
pollen avec ça on peut faire c'est le
miel de notre fils de tous ses amis à
venir de nos copines c'est le miel du
bois 30 à pauline donc ça c'est un miel
d'été c'est mieux de châtaignier
tilleuls et ronces c1
la conjugaison de ces fleurs il est
délicieux qui fleurissent à partir du
mois de juin jusqu'à la fin du mois de
juillet parce que je fais ma deuxième
récolte mondiale et le mieux c'est aussi
l'ingrédient principal nous parlent et
disent c'est un ingrédient principal des
premiers cas et pis on prépare cet
excellent pagny pis avec ce miel c'est
ta recette ça c'est ma recette
voilà c'est quelque chose que l'on a
envie de partager
mais on déguste par contre à partager
entre amis c'est quand même là et donc
on va attendre encore un bon jeu faire
une petite tranche ali allait occuper
ici on se le partagent
ça va être sympa vous allez merci bien
mais merci à toi de me faire découvrir
donc un biais pas depuis ce matin il
vient juste d'être fait là non parce
qu'il est vraiment hyper frais - le web
a presque comme de la brioche un peu
bien sûr merci beaucoup c'est ici que
s'achève notre séjour saint quentinois
vous l'avez vu cette ville nouvelle à
quelque chose d'étonnant mêmes
d'attachant et d'ailleurs si vous
souhaitez tout revoir
on se donne rendez vous sur terre de
france pointent tv
[Musique]